- The actual making of a film,
the day to day going to work,
the construction of a film,
has always been my favorite thing.
I'm going to go stand in the mirror,
and my wife's over there
watching, reading something,
I'm going to stand in the mirror
and I'm going to practice a move.
This is really embarrassing.
Well, too bad, man.
Do it in the mirror right now.
The $320, I was like, "Is this legal?"
'Cause it was so much fun and I was,
(laughs)
I was really looking
over my shoulder going.
(laughs)
Being an actor, or even being
an artist, and I had studied
in school behind the camera,
was not even in the vernacular
of my dreams.
- He's an Academy Award
winning American actor.
He achieved critical success
for portraying a cowboy
who was diagnosed with AIDS in
the Dallas Buyers Club movie.
He also starred in HBO's first
season of True Detective,
for which he earned an Emmy nomination.
He's Matthew McConaughey
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Number one is my personal
favorite, and make sure to
stick around all the way to end for some
special bonus clips.
Also, as you're watching and
listening, if Matthew says
something that you really
enjoy, make sure to leave
it in the comments below
with quotation marks,
so we know what you really enjoy.
(air rushes)
(thuds)
- The making, the actual making
of a film, the day to day
going to work, the
construction of the film
has always been my favorite thing.
I like making a film much more
than I like watching them.
I do. Even the one's I'm in.
I really love the coming
together with a whole bunch of
people having an idea on
paper, and everyone's an
expert at what they do and
you're off on this turn
and you got ideas but
then you just let them go
and see what it can become.
I love the making,
that's when I'm happiest,
is when I'm making a
film or telling a story,
the day to day.
And more so than watching them, really.
Look, I kind of defined that for myself
about four years ago.
Process. Stay in process.
Head down, in process.
Stay in your bubble and when it's over,
be that fulfillment.
Notice, when I started noticing
that fulfillment of it,
I just finished, well
that's enough, that's it.
I don't know if it's even
coming out, I don't even know,
I don't know what it's going to turn into.
Man I hope we got it.
And, I hope the director
put something good together,
but I don't know.
Nothing I can do about that.
All I know is that this
experience, that I said,
go have the experience, McConaughey.
And, if I can love this
experience and at the end of it,
I'm like may never even
hear that film again.
May never even know that
story again, it may be gone.
Let me find out that all
the negatives got fried
in the x-ray machine, there is
no film, but I've got to be,
(laughs)
that's okay, I had an experience.
When I got selfish for that, for that,
the experience, that process,
enjoying that process,
the day to day architecture
of making a movie
and creating a role.
That's when I've been the happiest.
And more results have come
that way, in an odd way.
- Yes.
- You know?
But, when I started to
really approaching them
as this is a finite thing and
this is just an experience,
other than that I'm not
producing this thing.
I'm not the one editing, I don't know what
it's going to be, that's it.
And then, all of a sudden
they come out and you go,
oh, I think we got a good one.
- [Interviewer] So, are you
surprised by the places you went
in that performance?
Are you surprised when you see it back
or are you already--
- No, not after I engaged,
not after I took the dare.
Soon as I got off the phone
call with him and then also when
he said it's not in the picture now, but I
think it'd be great if
Dallas danced at the end.
And my heartbeat went up
on the phone and I started
breaking a cold sweat like,
like going no that's not.
And, as soon as I went oh no that's not,
the other devil in my ear
said I (bleep) dare you do,
and I just went of course.
Yes, because I immediately
noticed, if you don't
you're wussing out dude,
are you kidding me?
You will forever regret, you have to.
So, as soon as I got over
that, I was like well
that's inevitable, I'm doing it.
Now, I got to bust my ass
to go do it the best I can.
And, there was a lot of fear in that.
I mean, that was
some majorly good anxiety and fear.
And then, now I'm
saying, and by that time,
now everything, my choices
from that phone call onward
anything I was ever set
you have to go (bleep).
Nah dude, go, all the way.
Go, meet midnight, yes.
Can you all meet in front
of the choreograph session?
Eight a.m. Sunday morning,
do you got an hour?
I'm going to go stand in the
mirror and my wife's over there
reading something, I'm going
to stand in the mirror,
I'm going to practice a move.
This is really embarrassing.
Well, too bad man, do it
in the mirror right now
because the less embarrassing that gets
hopefully the more comfortable you'll be
when you're out there
in front of 80 people
and a bunch of cameras.
And, one thing you do
when you go out there,
don't come up short.
(laughs)
Go, all the way.
- So, even with these
movies under your belt
you came out to L.A. and
you were still thinking
it was going to be for P.A. work.
- Still thought it was
going to be P.A. work.
I mean, I didn't know, it was still,
I was the leading (mumbles),
I mean, I sure did like
that I was doing it and I
had people and I couldn't,
honestly at that time the $320.
I was like is this legal?
'Cause it was so much fun.
And then, I was
(laughs)
I was really looking
over my shoulder going.
(laughs)
And, I kept getting invited back.
And then, I had people coming
up and going, "Hey man,
"You're good at this."
And, I was like, "Well thanks,
'cause it sure is fun."
So, I really didn't know.
I guess secretly, if I look back at it
and I look at my diaries
there was hope underlying,
but I always feel like I
need to go out and get a job.
And, if I can pursue acting on the side,
get a P.A. job, get in
the storytelling business
behind the camera and let's see.
Then, another funny thing happened.
That first audition when
I got out here was for
a casting director named Hank McCann.
You know who I'm talking about?
It was for a film called Boys on the Side.
And, I went and read and
he goes, "I think you did
"really good, I'll have you for
a call back sometime later."
I went off from there, I get called in
for a baseball film,
Angels in the Outfield.
I walk in the door,
there's a bunch of funny
peculiarities on how the hell I got to be
standing here today.
(laughs)
I walk in the door, I was back lit.
I had an American cap on, it
was a Warner Brothers lot.
I open up the door.
It was back lit in the
afternoon, producer's sitting
on the couch he looks up and goes,
"Hey, that's (mumbles),
the all American kid."
(laughs)
And then like, he goes,
"You ever play baseball?"
I said, "12 years."
He goes, "you got the job."
(laughs)
So, they send me, they pay me schedule f.
48 five,
(laughs)
$48,500 to go play baseball
for 11 weeks in Oakland.
Again, I'm going, "What
is this business, man?"
(laughs)
But, it happened.
And, during that I got
called back to read for
Harper Ross and Boys on
the Side and got that role.
So, that Cohen Brothers
film that got pushed,
that P.A. job that I would
have taken if it was there
never happened and I haven't P.A.'d since.
(laughs)
(crowd applauds)
And, I had about a year
and a half where I would
audition and I would get one call back,
two call backs, three call
backs, and I never got the part.
And, I remember feeling
like I'm too tight,
you know what I mean?
I think maybe I'm studying too much.
I remember talking to myself
and, "Maybe I'm studying
"too much about the import
of the line and everything
"and you know what?
"I think I need to go
back to doing what I did
"when I first started,
which is I was just a guy
"and I improvised."
So, I had a film that I was
cast for and I was playing
this on the border Mexican
drug lord and I told
myself I'm not going to look at the sides.
I'm not even going to read the script.
It's an on the border Mexican drug lord,
I hear the synopsis.
If I know my man then
I'll show up and just,
obviously, I'll read
it right before I go on
and if I know my man that'll be like,
"Well, that's exactly what he'd say."
(laughs)
Foolish, I go to set that morning,
all right, I'm just going
to, all I have to do
is have a glance at it and it'll be like,
"Yep, I know how to do it."
Well, I look at it,
right, before we're about
to say action and it was a page and a half
monologue in Spanish.
(laughs)
Oh, and I knew when I
felt this strip of sweat
come up on the back of my head and go down
and for whatever reason
I looked over and I said,
"Can you give me like 12 minutes?"
Why I said 12 minutes I don't know.
I figured it was like not long
enough to be inconsiderate,
but long enough to maybe get
a little bit of that stuff.
Anyway, I think I was horrible in it.
I stammered through some Spanish
and tried to look aligned.
So, then I was like, "Okay,
that's not the way to go."
(laughs)
There's a blend here of having
to do your due diligence,
do your studying but then
being able to go down
the day and relax and throw it all away.
I'm probably much more
intentional than people
would think I am.
I make choices.
I invest in 'em. I work on 'em.
And, I don't choose to
really share a lot of that,
it's my own private time.
I try and do the work
whether it's personally,
whether it's on a role, whatever it is
so I can then appear like
I'm blowing in the wind.
I call it create your
own weather so you can
blow in the wind.
It's conservative early, liberal late
is what I'm talking about.
See what sandbox you're playing in.
Any glass in here, no no glass.
Okay, there's the
boundaries, that's the rules.
Okay, now get four
dimensional in the sandbox,
now blow in the breeze.
I choose my direction, we're going east,
we're going north, we're
going south, or we going west?
All right, I got it,
this kid is going east.
Well now, you got 16 lanes to swerve in,
take an exit.
All you got to do to get
there, don't know how
we're going to get there.
We may have a long put
stop at the gas station.
We may pull off somewhere, we may stop.
But, one thing we're not
going to do is pull a u-turn
and go the other way.
Just stay in direction
and swerve all you want.
That's the liberal lane,
that's the blow in the wind.
So, I do my pre-production
work whether it's
yearly, whether it's in
the morning, when I wake up
in the morning having tea with myself.
I make a plan out for the
day or the week, year,
and then I kind of set
it out there and say,
"Now, how are we going to get there?
"I'm not sure, but it's there."
And, I'm happy to say that so many of my
goals and dreams that I've had
19 out of 20 that I wrote down in 1988
I completely forgot about 'em,
completely forgot about 'em.
I pulled the diary out last
year and 19 out of 20 I've done
and never once remembered
specifically saying,
"You got to do that."
So, it was in there, somehow
it was going after me
getting them but I never
remember trying to go get 'em.
Starting with Lincoln
Lawyer was a time I said
I wanted to recalibrate my
relationship with my career.
I remember saying that.
I remember thinking my
career, I'm enjoying it.
I love what it's given
me, I like going to work.
I like the things I've
been doing but everything
I started reading I felt
like, "Oh, it's like it's
"another version of something I've done
"or I feel like I could do it next week."
And, I remember going,
"Well, wait a minute
"before you get mad at
thinking you could do something
"next week, that's a valid feeling.
"Don't just say no to
something 'cause you feel like
"you could naturally do it."
But then I said, "Okay, fair,
I'll shake with you on that,
"McConaughey, but
(laughs)
"let me find something
that I don't know how,
"what to do next week or the week after.
"Let me find something that I really like,
"but I'm going (vocalizes) I'm not sure.
"Them that scares me,
that shakes my floor."
And, I was fortunate enough,
'cause that schedule f check I got
in Angels in the Outfield did
know that my rent was paid.
I was fortunate to know
my kids were going to eat.
I was just shepherding my
first son into the world.
So, I had that to take care of my time.
And, I said, "It's a great
time to go into the shadows
"and be a father and sit
back and see if something
"turns you on from the inside
or if something finds you
"if you're the target
that can draw you there.
"But, we're okay, rent's
paid, kids are going to eat.
"We can take some time off."
I in no way was thinking
about, "Like oh, I'm done."
But, I didn't know how long the dry spell
was going to go.
So, I said no to some
of the things that were
similar to what I had been doing before.
And, it took a while, I had
to sit down with my agent
and say, "Hey I'm really
going to do this and I need
"your help with my
commitment to this because
"after eight months if
the same thing comes in
"with the big 10 million dollar pay check
"it starts to read better and funnier."
(laughs)
I promise you, brother, I
mean they're the same words.
(laughs)
All of sudden, I think this thing's great.
I think I can find an angle.
I can make it a different
experience for me.
So, I said I'm going to need
your help bunkering down here
and saying no to some things.
And so, I'm going to need
you to be a gatekeeper
one to keep from getting too many, too.
Let's be real clear, I'm looking for some
different things to do.
He holed up, he handled that.
My wife, we said we don't know
how long it's going to be dry.
Then, after they quit sending
those then it did get dry.
Then nothing came for about a year,
- Wow.
- just nothing.
I didn't have any sleepless
nights or oh my gus.
It was like, "No, I'll find
something, I'll write."
I was writing a lot.
I was turning myself on
creatively and as I said,
I had my first son to
shepard into the world.
And then, a funny thing
happened, a beautiful thing
happened that somehow the
target drew the arrow.
And, I think, my opinion
is I became a new good idea
by removing myself.
I became William Friedkin
calls for the first time.
Stephen Soderbergh calls
for the first time.
Somehow in that two years
I became a fresh, new idea
that I don't think I was
two to three years prior.
How that works I'm not
sure because I didn't
send a memo out.
(laughs)
But, it did happen.
Being an actor or even being an artist,
and I had studied at
school behind the camera
was not even in the
vernacular of my dreams.
I was raised nine to five you go to work
you work your way up a scale.
- That's from your old man, right?
- Yeah, and that was
all I was able to even,
like I said dream about.
So, the idea of living
life and having a career
that was in the arts, that was
in the storytelling business,
that was something that was
really fun was not something
that, like I said, I even dreamed of.
I was in the right place,
right time, right bar.
A guy found me and said,
"You want to come in and read
"for a part in a movie "I'm here producing
"called Dazed and Confused."
I said, "Sure."
I go read for the part,
it's got three lines.
Three lines turns into three weeks work
they pay me $325 bucks a day.
People are telling me
I'm pretty good at it.
And, I think I'm getting
away with something.
And, I still do feel like I'm
getting away with something.
It's always been the most
important thing for me
to be the best man that I can be.
And, my rights as a
human being, number one,
then my rights as a citizen, number two.
Then, my rights or my
identity as an American,
a McConaughey, all those things
you can break down to family
from child of god if that's how you see it
to being a human to being a
citizen, to being an American
to being a Mconaughey,
all those identifications
you get to bringing it down to self.
Those are all, come before,
now I'm a famous actor,
or now I'm an actor who has become famous
or I am a celebrity.
Celebrity and fame are amendments
that came along the way.
Did they all of a sudden
propose many new challenges
with how to balance life?
You damn right they did.
Needed many times, I was
like, "God, can I have
"26 hours in this day instead of 24?
"I just need two more."
Man, it's all, and I'm not
sure, I'm not discriminating
enough, I'm not being discerning enough.
I'm kind of, everything sounds good.
Everything, all the
answers were no yesterday
in this career I'm taking on.
Boy, over one weekend everything's a yes.
It invertedly flip flopped.
Yesterday I had 99 noes
out of 100 scripts.
And, over one weekend after
a Time to Kill comes out
it flips, 99 yeses.
Great, but hang on a minute.
I got to, these things that I'm looking at
I'm going, well yes.
Three days ago I would
have said yes, to these.
I have to be much more discriminate
and really try to go, "let
me ask myself what it is
"I want to do."
That's not easy to do
because there's time.
This was it, more important, "Can I have
"26 hours in the day?"
You know what I mean, but I don't have it.
Disseminating between 'em,
walking that line of
really respecting this job
that I do as a real privilege
and an honor to do, at the same time
you got to go from being impressed
to getting really involved.
And, I find that if I
can get really involved
that doesn't lessen my
respect for a craft,
for something I'm doing.
It actually raises it
because it's a little more
of a shoulder look at it.
It's looking it eye to eye.
I mean, if you revere
you're never going to
engage with it as much
'cause you're always beneath it.
So, to get involved with it,
still respect it, don't
patronize it, okay understand it,
look down on it that's not healthy either.
But also, while you can respect
it, know it's a privilege
don't be beneath it, like, "Oh
my god, I'm just so thankful
"that this is just, oh just do it."
No, you need to look at it level and go,
"Okay, but why am I doing
this and what can I give
"and what can it give me back?"
There came a time while
we were working there
I was like, "Okay, the Dallas
Buyer's Club, we got to
"do that, like it fits in this year.
"And, I'm going to put it in
that slot, and it was like
in the fall."
And be like, okay, but it's not real.
We don't have the financing for it.
No, no, no we'll get that,
we'll get that, we'll get that.
It's happening in the fall, in the fall.
And, part of getting
that and he did Jean-Marc
he and I'd meet, he's interested in
some pieces coming together.
And, what we did is we
didn't flinch once we said
we were going to make it in that fall.
Whenever we didn't flinch
when people would go,
"You can't do this, you
don't have the money for it."
Which we didn't.
We're like, "no, no we'll
get it, it's coming.
"We got it, we're making it in fall."
And, we just never flinched.
And I remember I never had any doubt,
like I talked myself into it obviously
'cause hell I was wrong,
there wasn't money.
It caught up with us right
as we were making it,
it caught up with us.
The money fell out.
What money was there,
the money had fallen out
of this thing so many times.
What money was there and told to be real
turned out to not be real just a few weeks
before we started shooting.
And then, by that time
Jean-Marc and I'd be working
on the script and I had already,
I was already into this guy and I'd lost
a bunch of weight someone
said, "We may have to
"push to Spring."
And again, I didn't listen, I was like,
"No, we're not pushing to Spring.
"We're doing it this fall, we're going.
"it's set the date, we're there."
And, something about that
and I wasn't the only one
doing that, there was others, too.
The producers and Jean-Marc,
something about that
it's weird how some things
can get made in this town
by just blinding saying,
"No, it's happening."
And, if you get enough
momentum and don't even
consider the other options.
'Cause if you flinch,
if we'd have flinched
and said, "Spring," even that
would have been too much.
If would have left a sliver of light open
for somebody to go, "oh,
okay at least it's possible."
Then, the things that
happened just probably
wouldn't have happened.
So, yeah I said yesterday
it was turned down 86 times.
I got corrected last night, it turned out
the real count was it's
been turned down 137 times.
- Wow.
- So, that is like,
I don't know what makes this so fun.
We were never after the result with that,
just the getting of it
made was so visceral that,
but now it's around.
It's a year later and the movie translates
and then we're getting people
talking about the film,
the message, our roles.
It makes you very proud to
be here talking about it
because there was so much
skin left in the game
by so many people to get it made.
- Did Jim Morrison provide inspiration
for the Dazed and Confused character?
Is that true?
- Getting ready for that
role the first night
I went up for a dress
rehearsal and hair and make-up
and I stepped out of the
trailer and Rick Linkletter,
the director comes up
and goes, "This is great.
"Look at our Wooderson, this is great."
And he goes, "Listen
man, I know you're not
"supposed to work tonight
but we got a scene
"at the Top Notch, it's Friday night.
"I think Wooderson might be
there, trolling for chicks
"what have you, you know
what I mean?" He goes.
I go, "yeah, he would be there."
He goes, "What do you
think would Wooderson maybe
"be attracted to the
redheaded intellectual?
"'Cause Wooderson's been around school,
"he's kind of been with
all the typical beauties,
"what about the redheaded intellectual?
"Do you think he'd be into that?"
I was like, "Yeah," I
said, "Give me 30 minutes
"let me take a walk."
And he goes, "Okay."
So, I took a walk.
Come back, we played verbal ping pong.
I told him my ideas and he told me his.
And, he goes, "Want to shoot it?"
I went, "Okay."
So boom, we go up to the set.
I get in the car, I'm like I'm nervous.
First scene ever on film and right before
we're about to shoot I've
got friends in the car.
I'd been listening to
this live Doors album
and in between two of
the songs Morrison goes,
"All right, all right,
all right, all right."
You ever heard that recording?
- Of course.
- Right, the four, "all right, all right,
"all right, all right."
So, right before we're
about to go I'm like,
"What is Wooderson
about? What's he about?"
And I go, "Man, he's about four things.
"He's about his car,
he's about getting high,
"he's about rock and roll,
and picking up chicks."
And, I go, "I'm in my
car, I'm high as a kite,
"I'm listening to rock and roll," action,
"and there's the chick.
"All right, all right, all right."
Three out of four.
- That's fantastic.
- Thank you guys so much for
watching, I hope you enjoy.
I made this video because
Ash Wilson asked me to.
So, if there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me
to profile next leave it
down in the comments below
and I will see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Matthew's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why,
what clip resonated the most with you,
what change you're going to
make in your business now
after watching this clip.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join the discussion.
Also, if you like some
of the quotes that people
have left from Matthew from these clips
make sure to show your
appreciation by giving
those comments a thumbs up.
Finally, I want to give
a quick shout out to
Lee Kwoon Fai who recently
purchased 10 copies
of my book, 10 copies I
really appreciate that.
And hopefully, you can use it for yourself
and give it as some gifts away to people
that'll make an impact.
For those of you guys who want a chance
at a future shout out in a video make sure
to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe or
whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon.
(air rushes)
(thuds)
(vocalizes)
- Yeah.
Tootski.
- No, no thank you, though.
- Mister Hanna, what can I bring for you
on this glorious afternoon.
- Well Hector, here's the game plan.
You're going to bring
us two Absolut martinis,
you know how I like them, straight up.
And then, precisely seven
and one half minutes after
that you're going to bring us two more.
And then, two more after
that every five minutes
until one of us passes the (bleep) out.
(laughs)
- [Hector] Excellent strategy, sir.
- I'm good with water for
now, though, thank you.
- It's his first day on
Wall Street, give him time.
Thank you.
- Mm-hmm.
- Thank you.
Mister Hanna you're able
to do drugs during the day
and then still function,
still do your job.
- Well, how the (bleep)
else would you do this job?
Cocaine and hookers, my friend.
- Right.
I got to say I'm incredibly
excited to be a part
of your firm.
I mean, the clients you
have are absolutely--
- (bleep) the clients.
Your only responsibility is
to put meat on the table.
You got a girlfriend?
- I'm married, I have a
wife her name's Theresa
and she cuts hair.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Think about Theresa, name of the game,
move the money from your client's pocket
into your pocket.
- Right, but if you can
make the clients money
at the same time it's
advantageous to everyone, correct?
- No, number one rule of Wall Street,
nobody, okay if you're Warren
Buffet or Jimmy Buffet,
nobody knows if a stock
is going to go up, down,
sideways, or in (bleep) circles,
least of all stockbrokers.
It's all a fugazi, you
know what a fugazi is?
- Fugazee, it's a fake.
- Yeah, fugazee, fugazi
it's a wahzi, it's a woozi,
it's (whistles) fairy dust.
It doesn't exist, it's never landed.
It is no matter, it's not
on the elemental chart.
It's not (bleep) real, right?
- Right.
- Stay with me.
We don't create (bleep),
we don't build anything.
- No.
- So, if you got a client
who bought stock at eight
and now it sits at 16
and he's all (bleep) happy.
He wants to cash in,
liquidate, take his (bleep)
money and run home you
don't let him do that.
'Cause that would make it real.
- Right.
- No, what do you do?
You get another brilliant
idea, a special idea,
another situation, another
stock to reinvest his earnings
and then some.
And, he will every single
time 'cause they're
fucking addicted.
And then, you just keep doing this again,
and again, and again.
Meanwhile, he thinks he's
getting (bleep) rich,
which he is on paper, but
you and me the brokers
we're taking home cold hard cash
via commission, mother (bleep).
- Right,
(laughs)
that's incredible, sir.
I can't tell you how excited I am.
- You should be, there's
two keys to success
in the broker business.
First of all, you got to stay relaxed.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- You (bleep)?
- Do I (bleep)?
Yeah, yeah I (bleep), yeah.
- How many times a week?
- Like three or four times, maybe.
- I'd pump those numbers up.
Those are rookie numbers in this racket.
I myself I (bleep) at least twice a day.
- Wow.
- Once in the morning
right after I work out and then once right
after lunch.
- Really, mm-hmm.
- Okay, I want to, that's not why I do it.
I do it cause I (bleep) need to.
Think about it, you're
dealing with numbers
all day long, decimal
points, high frequencies,
bang, bang, bang, (vocalizes)
(bleep) (vocalizes).
All very acidic above the
shoulders mustard (bleep).
All right, it kind of
can wig some people out,
right you got to feed the geese
to keep the blood flowing.
Got to keep the rhythm below the belt.
- Done.
This is not a tip, this is
a prescription, trust me.
If you don't you will fall out of balance,
split your differential
and tip the (bleep) over.
Or, worse yet, I've seen
this happen, implode.
- Nah, I don't want to implode sir.
- No, no you don't.
- I'm in it for the long run, you know?
- Implosions are ugly.
- Yeah.
- Pop off to the bathroom, work one out
anytime you can and when
you get really good at it
you're (bleep) be
stroking it and you'll be
thinking about money.
Second key to success in this racket
is this little baby right here.
It's called cocaine.
- Right.
- It will keep you sharp between the ears.
It'll also help your fingers dial faster.
And, guess what, that's good for me.
Yes sir, revolutions, you follow?
- Revolutions.
- Keep the clients
on the ferris wheel and
it goes, the park is open
24/7 365, every decade,
every god dammned century.
That's it.
(laughs)
(glass clinks)
The name of the game.
(mumbles)
- Thank you.
(vocalizes)
(thuds)
Come on.
(vocalizes)
(thuds)
With a common denominator.
(vocalizes)
(thuds)
Keep it up for me.
♫ I'm CB (mumbles)
♫ And the money comes in
♫ The parade comes to town
♫ Going down Broadway
♫ It's a one way street
♫ Going whichever way I go♫
- Can you tell us anything
about that Mister Cohle?
(sighs)
That looks a lot like the one from 95.
But, you knew that already.
- Yeah, there is specifics
consistent to the 95 case.
Details that weren't public knowledge.
- You were off the grid
for eight years, right?
Show back up in 2010.
- My question is--
- How could it be him,
if we already caught him in 95.
How indeed, detectives.
- [Black Haired Detective]
I figured you'd be
the one to know.
(metal clangs)
- Then, start asking the
right (bleep) questions.
(funky music)
- Mister Woodroof, you can
listen to me for a moment.
I know this can be a very scary thing.
I know you're probably
feeling overwhelmed right now.
But, what we would like to
do is to impress upon you
the gravity of your situation.
Based on your health,
based on your condition,
based on all the evidence
we have we estimate
you have 30 days left to
put your affairs in order.
- 30 days?
- I'm sorry.
(phone rings)
- (bleep) this, what is this (bleep)?
(bleep) 30 days mother (bleep).
Let me give ya'll a little news flash.
Ain't nothing out there
that can kill (bleep)
Ron Woodroof in 30 days.
(papers rustle)